now MPs are warning that China's efforts
to downplay the corona virus pandemic in
its early stages cost lives and is
hindering the fight against the disease
the Commons Foreign Affairs Committee
claims the country where the virus
originated had sought to quotes
obfuscate over what was really happening
and what is trying to think about all
this I'm joined now by Minister mark we
of the Chinese embassy in London thank
you for joining us so the accusation is
that you've not been honest or open
about what was happening in the early
stages of the epidemic in Wuhan no I
couldn't accept that but first of all
let me say this my thought our thoughts
are with those who lost their loved ones
and also those people who are affected
mister with the virus perhaps including
the Prime Minister the Chinese
government has been very open
transparent and responsible in sharing
the information with the world including
with the United States and many other
countries
yeah but the official line on December
the 31st was there was no clear evidence
of human-to-human transmission but we
know there were more than doctors of
told us there were more than a hundred
cases and 15 deaths in Wuhan between
December the 12th and the end of the
month and it was still the official line
in January the 20th but there was still
no human to human transmission but
doctors were being infected and dying
and many people were being infected and
dying I think you are talking about the
initial first months of the outbreak of
the epidemic to say when the first of
three cases were detected on the 27th of
December and China ordered a lockdown of
whoo-hah and a hoobie province on the
23rd of January has happened actually
during this 40:20
27 days and this is this is a new virus
and we were working very hard to find
out what was the virus because
originally the doctor the John GCM
reported on the 27th of December that
three cases of pneumonia with animal
causes was bought it so she reported to
the authorities health authorities local
governments and local health Commission
and of a National Health Commission and
the CBT of China we are working very
hard unify this what is this virus so at
initially they said there was limited
evidence of human transmission but with
a very senior SS group from the National
Health Commission was sent to Han led by
perhaps the most well know Chinese
responsibly and expert dr. joe manchin
and they decided that it carries
humility but Minister ma your doctor Li
Li wen Yang who later died from the
virus sent out a warning on the whatsapp
group on on December 30th four days
later he was arrested and accused of
making false statements but he was right
why did you arrest him and accuse him
and make him false statements he turned
out to be right I'm a little bit
surprised better people come back again
a game on the case of dr. new India let
me say this
dr. Lavinia was not a whistleblower top
as I mentioned earlier dr. John GCN a
doctor of the ICU director of ICU of the
hospital of Chinese and Western medicine
first reported the pieces and reported
to the Chinese government both locally
and the national government and the
local health Commission's and the
central government acted upon her advice
her report and the governance for spread
into action with regard to talk to live
yeah first of all he was a doctor he was
not a response doctor he was not a
epidemiologist he only us he was sharing
any information on a witch head group
yes but he was saying that there was
infection doctors were getting infected
doctors with excuse me doctors were
getting infected and that people were
getting infected in quite large numbers
so he said there was human to human
transmission let me say this at the time
when he was sharing information yes we
tread group the government was has
already taken action the government was
investigating the base case so
identified what kind of a virus this
work this is worse of course he was not
sharing very accurate information but
site okay so the choice first interrupt
you so turn toward you the charge is
that the delay meant that the other
countries around the world could not
prepare and that it may have cost lives
so my other question is why did you
close travel from Hubei Province to the
rest of China at around Chinese New Year
but flights to places like London and
Paris and Rome and New York were kept
open well perhaps there are two levels
of issue when well is that the hoobat
authorities indeed stopped issuing
passports for people to traveling to
travel outside of the province let alone
also after China so the Chinese
government already won't against travel
unless it is not essential so not many
people are travelling outside will hire
or outside to obey only another level
other governments could have took
actions actually the United States
imposed a travel ban on the 2nd of
February for Chinese travelers or other
travelers who went through China in the
past 40 days you cannot blame China for
your action on the part of some other
governments you could have taken some
things like sue cranium Chinese
visitors to their countries and
determine whether they are infected or
not okay so let me ask you this so yeah
I understand so let me ask you this have
you determined exactly where the virus
came from did it come from a wet market
in Wuhan no not yet
originally it was a thought the virus
might have come from the West markets
because some of the patients were
associated with the market but it is
equally true there some of the patients
that doctors saw had no contact with a
wet with the wet markets so the exact
origin of the virus has not yet been
determined yet so it's reversible so
it's possible it came from a virology
laboratory in Wuhan is that at all
possible that's been mentioned no I mean
of course the origin of the virus should
be determined by scientists and
estimates and doctors
so we should leave this issue to the
doctors to the scientists but overall
but it's impossible sorry - sorry to
interrupt your is it possible it came
from a virology laboratory in Wuhan you
let me let me finish as if you ask
question I'll give you answer
yeah many scientists have published a
epidemic paper saying that the virus was
the reproduct
of the nature so they have ruled out the
possibility of a virus engineered in a
lab which means the conspiracy
conspiracy theories of a virus
originating from the Chinese lab or from
a u.s. there was not funded at this age
so we basically leave this important
issue to the scientific to the sign to
the science is it so important okay
yeah absolutely Stalin rumbly and this
submission yeah have you closed down I
know you say you've closed down some of
the wet markets can you guarantee that
they will stay closed will you will you
stop the wet markets reopening let's say
this
let's first talk about wet markets in
Wuhan the city as far my information is
the market remained closed and has not
yet has not yet opened whether it will
not open or not now it's reaching full
government notice I can also share you
with the ether nation in fact the
Chinese Parliament has adopted a
decision to ban illegal wildlife trade
and also the consumption of the meat of
wild animals so there will be measures
to follow up with this decision so I
guess the law enforcement departments
will enforce that decision and will
impose okay why not treat yeah just
finally what is the true number of dead
in your country can you promise the
world
can you guarantee the world that the
numbers you are giving or have given are
your best and honest judgment look dudes
be don't be cynical this is an epidemic
and the China is a big country and also
there are so many foreign journalists
what details groups in China so it's to
hide and the official people to stand at
around three thousand three hundred
people who died off Crona forever
coronavirus and we have been very open
and transparent and responsible and
those who say a China people I or China
give a round figure
they don't didn't produce any evidence
and the Joint Commission to Tonga
commented fetta that figures status from
the Chinese side are credible so better
rely on the experts advice of the whu-oh
rather than some people making up the
figures okay
Maori I'm sorry this very important time
we need to work together solidarity is
more is important rather than blaming or
spreading disinformation okay mark ye
Minister mafia we appreciate your time
and we wish that all the best to the
people of China thank you very much
thank you stay safe this day draft the
UK thank you very much